Speaker 1: So Republican Senator Mitt Romney
was brutally booed and according to people
in the room called a traitor by Republicans
at the Utah State Republican Convention this
weekend, you have to hear this and this.
We're kind of on a search for answers to a
very seemingly simple question.
That question is whether the Republican Party
is the party of Donald Trump.
Is it still the party of Donald Trump or will
the Republican Party go back to being the
party of someone like Mitt Romney, people
like Romney, John McCain and the like?
One data point has been the really consistent
polling where the vast majority of the Republican
electorate still says, we like Trump, we believe
Trump won in 2020.
We would vote for Trump again.
We want Trump to remain involved in politics.
That's one data point.
Utah held its Republican convention this weekend,
and there was not only an attempt to censure
Mitt Romney by Republicans, which almost passed
more on that in a second.
Romney was extensively booed by his own fellow
Republicans, interrupting his speech multiple
times.
Take a look at this video.
Take a listen to this audio.
Unidentified: His first hundred days.
You know
Speaker 2: me as a person here who says what
he thinks, and I don't hide the fact that
I wasn't a fan of our last president's character
Unidentified: issues.
Aren't you embarrassed?
And I'm also no fan of the.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that is really something
else, you know, in the relatively anti Trump
Republican state of Utah.
Utah is not I don't know what's a state where
I mean, like South Carolina, Republicans like
Trump much more than Utah Republicans like
Trump.
And even in the relatively anti Republican
Trump state of Utah, Romney is still booed
relentlessly.
And those very Republicans pushed a motion
to censure Mitt Romney because he had the
audacity to think for himself in the Trump
impeachment trials and vote to convict on
some of those counts.
So they held the vote to censure Romney.
It failed, but barely seven ninety eight to
seven 11 really close vote given that these
are supposedly anti Trump Republicans.
Romney reportedly left the venue almost immediately
after finishing his speech.
And of course, the real question here is,
what does this mean for the future of the
Republican Party?
I don't know that it's totally obvious that
rejecting the Romney wing is necessarily bad
for the Republican Party.
What I mean by that is Trump individually
completely backfired for Republicans.
Trump got elected in 2016.
Republicans lost the House in twenty.
Eighteen, Republicans lost the Senate in 20
20.
Republicans lost the White House in twenty
twenty.
But Trump ism and by that I mean no policy.
You just fight cultural battles.
You oppose the Libs.
You try to anger people on the left that may
have more staying power as an approach.
If people other than Trump are the ones pushing
it, we just don't have an answer yet.
Twenty, twenty two will be a partial answer.
Do people in the Romney wing get removed in
twenty twenty two?
And do people in the Trump wing like Lauren,
Bobert, Madison, Taylor Green, Madison Cawthorn
get reelected?
Noticed that Mitt Romney's views have not
really changed much since 2012 when he was
the Republican nominee.
Most of the people in that room who are booing
him now, if they were old enough to vote in
2012, voted for Mitt Romney, this is more
a sign of how far off the deep end the Republican
electorate is.
It's similar, actually, to remember the situation
with the late Senator John McCain.
John McCain was a very popular Arizona Republican
senator, was the Republican presidential nominee
in 2008, lost to Barack Obama.
They chose him to be their nominee in 2008.
All of them, almost all of them voted for
McCain in the general election.
And then just eight years later, in 2016,
when Trump starts with, I prefer war heroes
who didn't get captured.
And Trump ridicules McCain's military service.
A lot of those same Republicans were cheering
when Donald Trump went after McCain in 2016.
Now, it is true that Sarah Palin, McCain's
vice presidential running mate in 2008, was
a sort of Proteau champion figure.
But regardless, consider the trajectory.
These same Republican voters are now calling
one of their previous nominees a communist
in Mitt Romney.
That all being said, Trump activated new people
who never participated in politics before.
So some of the boos you're hearing are presumably
people who simply weren't engaged at all in
2008 and 2012, but many were.
And now they've decided the people we thought
were the good choices in 2008 and 2012.
Now we boo them.
Now we call them communists.
Now we call them traitors.
The same Republicans who do not care at all
about policy, but are about how bad cancel
culture is.
Now, we're loudly trying to cancel any Republican
who's even mildly normal.
And that's the way I would describe Mitt Romney
cautiously, I would say is mildly normal.
Twenty twenty two is going to be wild and
it's going to be really significant in terms
of the future of the Republican Party.
And we're going to be watching it.